Thank You Joseph I know something about
hosting parties so I want to
congratulate you on being the perfect
host tonight you set the table faded
into the background and let the
interesting people shine what a dais
Dennis Rodman where do I begin if you
had told me back in the 90s that Dennis
Rodman would be negotiating a nuclear
arms agreement in the 2018 I would have
said Dennis Rodman is alive in 2000
local comedian Dahmer era is here dumb I
know your career never really took off
but if you just keep doing what you've
been doing
I'm sure you'll eventually be discovered
by your landlord two weeks after your
heart attack and Edward Norton I am a
huge fan you are amazing Edward takes
the craft of acting very seriously he
prepared to play The Incredible Hulk by
spending 30 years losing his temper and
turning into a giant asshole Nikki
Glaser you have it all the name of a
professional porn star and the body of
an amateur porn star you know I'm a big
supporter of the meetcha movement but
remember Nikki me too shouldn't just be
what a guy says to his friend when he
tells him he had sex with Nikki Glaser
there are so many celebrities here
tonight we have men from movies women
from TV and lil rel from I'm guessing
the California Raisins
[Applause]
[Music]